the established media in the United
States faces a serious problem the
reputation of even highly respected
award-winning publications like the
Washington Post has been eroded in a
tough election campaign media reporter
Paul Farhi has been observing the
relationship between journalists and
consumers for years he says this year
has seen a deep shift they do trust us
when they see something that they agree
with they mistrust us when they see
something that doesn't favor their point
of view I have to tell you that the
people who supported Trump were very
vocal in criticizing us in denouncing us
and saying we're liars on the other hand
the people who supported Hillary Clinton
also said the same thing from a
different perspective this fundamental
distrust of established media has fueled
the rise of Breitbart its headlines are
a mixture of agitation against
immigrants and deletes on Election
evening in the u.s. Breitbart had more
users on its Facebook profile than CNN
or Fox News by so how is this new
competition going to change journalism I
understand our job isn't to promote the
president our job is to tell you
important information about him it
whether it's flattering or it's not
flattering Breitbart on the other hand I
think we'll select the news to create
the image of a successful administration
so our Breitbart readers only looking
for news that confirms to their own
political opinions not so says Breitbart
fan and former diplomat Jim's atras well
I think Breitbart and along with several
other publications of what we call the
alternative media when they're right or
libertarian or left are a function of
the decline of public confidence in the
so-called mainstream media that there
was a recent poll that's seventy percent
of Americans don't believe what they see
in read in the mainstream media and he
says bright part isn't just profiting
from a distrust of the media but from a
rebellion against the established elites
prompt selection does represent
something of an uprising of the of the
working middle class in this country and
a reassertion of national identity
against a kind of a corrupt globalist
leader Hillary Clinton was the face up
Breitbart now plans to expand an open
offices in France and Germany Nikki
usher is a media analyst focusing on
online publications she believes the
European right will profit from bright
but those white supremacists have always
been there the problem is is that they
now have a platform they have a platform
to publish on that is very highly read
and they have sort of a gathering point
to sort of say that this is a place that
expresses their views and I think that's
what's deeply concerning to me right but
certainly appears confident it has
identified a big market for right-wing
conservative content during upcoming
elections in France and Germany in 2017